hi Shiva Banerjee and I'm a research
scientist working in love machine
learning team at Wolfram research and
today I will be talking about importing
neural networks with onx and it just
talks about all the difficulties would
be when that he had in the last one year
or so loading models manually and by
automated tool is required for important
networks thank you
oh so I am to schita and I work as a
research scientist in the machine
learning team at Wolfram research so I'm
presenting a work which is mostly done
by my coworkers and just trying to take
over the project right now so with my
other co-workers so it's mostly done by
James and materials or just giving the
credits where it's to and I will try to
present it to the best of my abilities
and also talk about why this project is
important in our team so I realized when
I was presenting this that we do not
have any other talks that introduce all
the models in the repository so but the
title of the talk was already decided
that it's going to be or in an ex
importer so I just thought I'll hijack
it a bit and talk about all the models
that we added since 12 so it's not since
last tech conference but it's since last
release cycle so it's since 12 we have
added these models in the repository
feel free to go ahead and check them out
they are the newer models I will talk
about one importance model and try to
say why we need or nnx or what
difficulties we faced trying to get that
model in the repository so so there are
no automatic tools anymore so we had a
MX net importer and we did have an
unofficial torch importer but as
research progress most of the models are
developed in PI torch and tensor flow so
if you have to get any external model
into our framework we need either a PI
torch or a tensor flow converter or do
it by hand doing it by hand is extremely
time consuming it is very err earnest
and it's tedious so you make the
architecture you take the weights you
parse the weights you link the weights
to the architecture and
you of these neural nets have around 800
to 900 layers the newer ones and doing
this kind of thing by hand is not a fun
thing to do I have done a few of them
and it was not the best time
so just that's why we were like oh we
need a automatic converter and that's
why we we are trying to build on an X so
this is sort of the code of this is not
here with me so Bob made this cord where
it shows the number of models that have
been added since the repository since
the neural net repository started you
can see there is a little bit like less
increase in the growth but we have
continuously added several models to the
repository one of the explanation why
there are fewer models is what we
started doing since 12 we started
introduced something called
parameterised net models which means
many of these models which slightly
differ in architecture or slight or
differ in the data set which it was
trained on they all come on the same
class so if you saw the repository
before you would have seen like there is
there are like eight or ten models of
cycle gans doing zebra - horse horse -
zebra apple - orange or whatnot but
right now all of those similar models
will be in one in one name so that is
not like an exponential growth and you
can see the it's more organized per se
so let's go ahead and see one of them so
the mobile net which was image
classification image task image
classification network that was
introduced in 2018
if I am correct or 918 yeah so it this
brings down the size of image
classification networks by around
anywhere between one tenth to one
hundredth and they are also faster
because they have fewer parameters and
they were like it says is they were
supposed to run on handheld devices
that's why they were made
so these kind of networks have a lot of
different parameters so again if we just
published them like we did before there
would be 22 model certainly added to the
repository and it just get it just made
it longer and longer so what we came up
is the parameter parameterization that
model I think this is a good place to
show the parameter in that model
machinery you will find some of these
functions in the neural net repository
page of that particular model but some
of them are not there so I just thought
I will show some of the model as some of
the options that's not mentioned in the
notebooks so you can find out all the
parameters you can find the default
variants so if you just query neck model
of this name you would get the default
variants or without the default variant
here it just shows which one is the
default variant so for many of these all
particular all the combinations will not
be available because as you can see if
they're where all of them I think you
would have gotten I think there are five
and five twenty five or thirty of these
I think only twenty two not I think I
know they're at only twenty two
available so for things that's there it
will return you the particular model for
combinations that are not allowed if you
just try to get all the variants it will
just fails with the appropriate message
saying that that that combination is not
allowed so this is something which is
not there in the in the example page so
I thought this is an important example
that they can show but yeah so you can
just pick a non-default one by just
changing the parameters the default one
was one point four and two twenty four
so I just pick a non-default one you can
similarly you can pick a non-default
uninitialized net that sort of machinery
is still there and then you just predict
it predict a non-default one and it
gives click normal prediction which is
this is like the image which is there in
all classification image classification
problems
so that's just introducing the
parametrized net models there are even
greater use of these parametric models
so if you see the bpe model it has
subvert embeddings for various languages
of different vocab size and different
dimensions of embedded vector and there
is no possible way that we could just
have like an exponent there are like 275
languages here that we could have so
many different languages scatter in the
neural net repository page so that's why
again justification of wipe the
parameterize net model machinery is
required so again similarly you have and
it's just a similar example where you
can get an unknown default untrained net
you can get the encoder you can this is
just an example of the VP model so we
can just go over it quickly so VP just
converts the segment into words or sub
words depending upon the vocabulary that
it has and it will output an integer for
each token so the token could be a word
or could be a sub word so that might not
be just one is to one ratio here so
again it could tokenize in any language
so this is like a ping written for
different languages and here it just
compares it to different languages so I
don't think so
I just know Bengali I think that's the
only one which I contributed in this in
this example the rest of it was again
from different as you know we have a
very varied more global company so I
guess everybody got one like we we
connected examples but I know I gave the
Bengali one so it's something for the
brain
I wasn't expecting that question though
[Music]
so yeah but okay so now I come to the
main part of it is like what's the
problem with hand conversion and why we
need or nnx so here is a very famous
model that was released on I remember
this day it was released on 14 February
2019
and so yes I saw that Timothy but yeah
it was released on 14 five 2019 and this
is what the model is and we had a heart
or at least I had a hard time trying to
convert this model by hand so again this
is also a parameterised net model Devers
feature extraction there's language
modeling and different sizes of the net
so you can all in all when you when it
comes to the repository you can pick
them and then it's all pretty and nice
and the model will come like whatever
you ask for it it will just return that
thing but behind the scenes like first
let me just describe the model here so
so we have this net encoder function so
it's a it's the function net to encode
and not any of the built-in one and
creating this function also the so it
has all the dirty pre-processing that
gp2 model GPT to model had so it has bpe
suffered tokens and then it also has a
conversion from utf-8 to you liked the
ASCII codes and there are there is this
part and then there is an extra
pre-processing part to the bpe server
tokens but all of it is covered in this
like small nice-looking net encoder
function you can definitely query keep
on extracting from there so that if you
want to modify the net encoder function
you can as well do that but yeah that's
the
all there in that encoder function
that's all the pre-processing and you
can also query for different positions
or not but in general it does things
very similar to the BBE
encoder it will convert a string into a
list of tokens so that's what it is
doing and it also has another thing it
needs to give the positional index here
so it also gives something like 1 2 3 4
5 6 like shows the position in your the
position of the token in the string so
again a lookup is done so ultimately it
gives a vector of size 768 for GP yeah I
don't know if I took the large one or
the smaller one but it is 1 0 2 4 or 768
depending upon the size of the model
that I am using and this is what you see
like these are the embeddings and then
you can find out and then you can find
out so this is the embedding part of it
so you have to embeddings the input
which gives the tokens the positional
embeddings and then you just add them
together and get the embedding part of
the architecture then what you have is
what is a new sort of architectural
paradigm that's called transformers
which were introduced in a paper called
all you need is attention and it has it
had two different things an encoder and
a decoder so GPD 2 has what's called the
transformer decoder and again another
equally famous NLP model called Burt has
what's called the transformer encoder
the difference between the two is causal
masking versus non causal masking so
this is what's the causal attention so
it always looks towards the thought it
looks forward in time so this is what GP
g2 has and Burt has self attention so it
looks both ways in time so anyway I
think I will run out of time if I keep
describing the architecture but the
take-home message was doing this 800
or a thousand layer network by hand was
not a happy job so what so what it was
is like you have to create the
architecture so this is the code that's
creating the architecture you keep
adding the model parameters then you
import the weights so this one was just
importing it with external evaluate and
then get the weights then parse them by
hand so this is where I pass the weights
by hand do the replacements by hand and
then finally you get the network so
that's why we were like no we need onn X
so that we don't have to do this manual
conversion every time we get a famous
model again we also could not like it
was not a fast process it takes quite
some time to get all of this done and
tested the other thing about why we need
our n NX importer is that we don't
really need to maintain a single
convertor
for every kind so we had an X net
converter and a torch converter but
again if we have all of them together
there's nothing like it so n n X gives
us that advantage and then it has a
model zoo there are not a lot of models
but they are adding it we also plan to
add models so there is there is a way
where you can take a model from they
have these tutorials to convert models
from say PI torch or tensorflow
and then convert it to o n n X so even
if a model is not there in the
repository in the model zoo you can
actually manually convert you can
actually follow those tutorials convert
it to or in an X and then convert from
Orion and X to Wolfram language also it
gives access to tools like core ml where
you can make your own apps so that's
something that is also good so that you
can have them in your handheld devices
and then there are other tools in onn x
so this optimizer there is runtimes
there are various hardware optimizations
there
is also shape influences we can we can
talk about them a little bit but yeah so
this is what the official onn X this is
from their site so I just put the court
quotation mark so it's an open format to
represent deep learning models and what
the aim was to move models from like
between state-of-the-art tools and
choose which is best for them and it's
it was developed and supported and they
have this huge list of community
partners what like who supports or nnx
and it's huge it's it's maintained by a
lot of different famous it's actively
developed by a lot of different peoples
so we think that this might not be one
tool that might get scraped in future
because as the film progresses and it's
so fast-moving you think that okay this
is it this is the framework where
everybody will stick to but in two or
three years it changes so I feel since
it has gotten a lot of backup from
different bigger companies it will still
continue so that's why also we need to
have something like this so let's go
ahead and describe the Orang annex
project so the reason why I'm spending a
lot of time in this is because
ultimately what I'm going to show with
importer is just import the model and it
will just take very less time so it's
better for me to sort of sure say what
the project is all about so again it's
open neural network exchange I don't
know why it is o N and E or not X before
somebody asks that question so the the
best thing is framework in
interoperability so you have most of the
important framework so cafe to CTN k MX
net and PI Taj and also tensorflow so
that's this is like that this is their
symbol for o n NX it shows like you can
just convert
one framework to the other there also
hardware optimization tools in onn X and
also good visualization tools that's
also sometimes missing in many of these
frameworks is a good visualization tool
so they also provide visualization tools
Hardware optimization is not done yet
like we have not hooked that up but it
is there are runtimes and libraries that
are designed to maximize the performance
so it's streamlining research to
productions if you want to use it yeah
so Amazon like the framework if you are
talking again not to be quoted none of
these frameworks are owned by any
companies but what is the company which
provides the maximum developer to a
certain production Amazon does a mix net
and Facebook does Python and Google does
tensorflow
it's not official but like they are all
open frameworks but that's where their
majority of the developers contribute to
maintaining the code of the frameworks I
have seen Nvidia use both PI torch and
tensor flow but in general I read like a
thing that mostly the the company like
the business people / it yeah the
corporate people are more using tensor
flow there was a recent publication and
academic research is happening more in
PI touch personally I feel PI touch is a
is a little bit easier to learn than
tensor flow but tensor flow also has
chaos - which came out so I feel like
that is also there but whatever it is
it's like competing with each other and
we want models from both of them into
our framework and this is the way to go
as a result like that's why you are in
NX so anyway so I have five minutes of
presentation time now I will actually go
to the code so so each of them is a it's
a graph
and it's it is a computational graph
model so there's a proto buff that is
stored in a protobuf format so there are
operators that are implemented so each
of the nodes can have more one or more
inputs and one or more outputs and then
the operators they are implemented
externally to the graph and each of
these operators should be portable
across frameworks so what we what we do
is add operators that are compatible
with Mathematica so and onn X operator
has to have one is to one correspondence
with a layer or a bunch of layers in
Mathematica and that's what we are
trying to build so that's how this works
and and the graph has nodes which are
the operations it has the waves that's
how we import the model and it has
different metadata so let's go ahead and
demo it with an example the reason why I
did not push the notebook into into
possible is because this is not added to
the bills yet so as a result of which I
am just adding the packet data tree and
showing it to the demo but it will be
hope it will be available in 12.1 so
that's why it's just just packing a
directory ad and it just works in my
computer twelve point one cycle known
you know twelve point one hopefully that
comes out before 2021
hopefully so so yeah
so calculate directory add of that and
then you get the this is this is just
internal code to get the edge the packet
but here is where interesting stuff cuts
so this is one of the internal function
that takes the model so that's in the
protocol format that the graphical
format and converts into mathematical
Association so this is what this
function actually does and you can just
see the Association and see okay so
there's a graph that's the graph that's
built and then each of the graph has
nodes like I said so each of the nodes
is
operator what's an operator it's like a
layered in Mathematica why not do layers
so that's that's how the graph looks
like
so again the key part of this
association is a graph so we can get all
that we can we can query about the graph
that's the most important one but other
than that there are other keys or other
things that you can query most of them
are like metadata so you have the onn x
ir version the opposite version so they
keep updating the opposite version the
producer name where it came from the
version and the model name domain all of
them might be there or all of them like
it could be there or could not be there
let's see for this model if I scroll
down so most of it is the graph and it
has all the operations and all the
weights and stuff and then you have all
the metadata so these are all the
metadata that's available for this and
again you can see it's it was done in
cafe 2
some of it is absent as well so ok so
that's that's mostly what's there in the
Association then you have the graph the
graph has different knowns
so these are the different notes I think
I'll spend some time so what the it's
the first of the node again a graph has
all of the layers and all of the
connections I'm just taking the first
one here so that's this is the input
like we said we could have radius input
so this one is the data this one gives
the weight and the biases of the layer
it's a convolution of the operation type
is convolution so it's a convolution
layer and again convolution layer has
different parameters so that's the
stride of the convolution that is one
one cross one stride so it's a 2 cross 2
convolution with one cross one stride
then you have padding then it gives you
the kernel shape so these are all the
properties of the convolution layer that
you would need to convert into a
mathematical layer and then so this
gives you the graphical connections and
the other thing you need to convert a
model is the widths so this gives you
the weights so this is the initialize a
in
and it this one gives you the weight of
the model so again there are other
things that you can get from the info so
these are all the dimensions of the
layer so that's that's that's a 22 like
that's the size of those image net
images that's the size that you start
with because they our data would be 224
cross 224 and then so this is okay and
then you convert it to a 64 dimension so
that's the number of channels you have
but we don't really need to worry about
all of this if you have your own model
and hopefully when it is imported you
can just do a nnx import and give the
name of the model so I will skip the
rest of the demos which are very similar
so these are the demos that work I have
also shown to be very honest demos that
don't work because that means I need to
work on those stuff so this is more of a
reminder for me what doesn't work so
sorry about this I'll just skip through
all the demos that work and let's come
to something that doesn't work so these
are all good things that work here the
evil things start things don't work from
here and if you can see these like you
will get some errors like the reshape
operator doesn't have badge dimensions
so we need to support these kind of so
we need to add badge dimensions to most
of the operators or try to find the
corner cases how it will work so that's
what we are working on so most of the
thing you'll see so there's badge
dimension broadcasting these are the
stuff that we need to add for each of
for some of you of these layers for
these models to work and that also
brings us to future work I thought this
is a good way to introduce all the
future work the strengths I think I have
already mentioned that it's being
actively developed and it has big
companies supporting it and it supports
many frameworks the weaknesses of the
owner next thing is I think mostly is
like RNN is not actively supported we
are trying to give support to our n ends
in
things encoders and decoders like the
net encoder net decoder that we have the
pre-processing and the post-processing
step I don't think so it's currently
planned but once you pick the get the
bigger architecture in figuring out
encoder and decoder is like 70% the 30 I
think
60% of the work is done you have to
figure out the rest 40% and also these
are the next steps that we were thinking
of to add RNN support the hyper network
but only static hyper Nets and hook up
to inputs so like you saw it was onx
import bye-bye 12.1 it should be just
import and then ona next should be a
format that is added but it's like very
very like more more future work that was
immediate future work so the immediate
future work is to add those badge
dimensions and stuff
the second immediate was RNN and then
more and more in the future is hook up
other tools like version and shape
inference and model checkers and the
exporter that requires the protocol
exporter so and improving operator
coverage is like a work which is in
progress that keeps happening so I think
that's it yeah you know
[Applause]